what's going on guys welcome back to
geek culture explain and the more i
thought about the loki series the more i
started thinking about more characters
who either need tv shows
or need to appear in the marvel
cinematic universe so i've put together
a list of
five people that i want to see in the
mcu
tv shows movies or otherwise so coming
in at number five
i'd love to see it loki i doubt we will
the living tribunal
mostly because of the fact that i feel
like the living tribunal would be just
this
hugely imposing figure right the living
tribunal for those of you guys who don't
know
is an answer to the question what if the
multiverse could just get up and walk
around technically eternity is two but
he's more of a recent creation in marvel
comics as far as the multiversal
eternity
as opposed to just the universal
eternity but the living tribunal is
incredibly powerful
and whenever you see him he's enormous
he's absolutely huge
although sometimes he has appeared
really small the first time that he
appeared in the doctor strange comics
back in strange tales
he was a little bit taller than stephen
strange maybe twice as tall as steven
strange but it wasn't like
bigger than a planet right i mean when
it comes to characters of that magnitude
of power they can make themselves any
size they want to be and usually
appearing as huge beings is designed to
kind of demonstrate the amount of power
that they have but nonetheless the
living tribunal would be an awesome
character to see if for no other reason
than the fact that it would give us a
little more clarity in terms of
how the multiverse functions what form
it plays whether or not there's actually
anybody out there keeping it organized
outside of the tva because
as much as i do love the tva they're
only one facet right you've got altezza
the custodian of the multiverse you've
got the omniversal development court you
have all kinds of stuff like that
and that leads us into number four
the omniversal development court this
whole thing is led by saturnine right
the omniversal magistrix
and the only reason why i want to see
the omniversal development court is
because it would give more credence to
brian braddock to captain britain see as
a comic book fan i
love multiversal stuff i left things
that deal with all these crazy huge
complex situations and when you look at
something like the omniversal
development court it'd be really cool to
see how they play with regards to other
universes that exist out there so those
of you guys who don't know what this is
the omniversal development court exists
to make sure that universes
evolve the way they're supposed to so if
we go by the old school marvel uk
captain britain's stories by alan davis
and alan moore then basically all this
told us
is that the unreversal development court
ensures that like mutants exist
on earth on alternate realities and that
the avengers come along somewhere along
the line
in these alternate realities one of the
things we've talked about before in one
of the moments when
everything with the omniversal
development court went awry was when
they initiated something called the push
if the universal development court goes
to an alternate reality and they realize
that there is nobody there who has
mutant powers or there are no avengers
or there's no superpower beings
whatsoever
they'll initiate the push to kind of
begin the process of getting those genes
going
getting those powers manifesting and
then just kind of call it a day and the
idea behind this was that the omniversal
development court and saturnine came to
the realization
that in the universe which was numbered
earth 238 that there was nobody that had
powers there and that was due to a guy
named mad jim jaspers jim jaspers was
basically a guy who could alter reality
and what he did is he created a being
called the fury that essentially had the
power to adapt to any powers
anywhere and then figure out anybody's
weaknesses and use those to their
advantage
this led to the fury literally going
across the world and killing every
single superhero it came across
and jim jaspers was the only person with
any powers left he did this because by
his own admission
he didn't want any competition
ultimately captain britain brian
braddock ends up in that universe
and the omniversal development court
initiates the push jim jaspers gets
pissed and he initiates the jasper's
wharf
which literally starts twisting and
skewing that whole universe to the point
when they actually had to destroy that
universe in order to keep it from
infecting the multiverse
but that's the role the omniversal
development court plays making sure that
universes evolve the way they're
supposed to and wouldn't it be cool if
the marvel cinematic universe becomes a
multiverse and then we in turn find out
that in other universes
there are mutants who are there but they
haven't popped up for whatever reason of
the marvel cinematic universe in the
main universe so
the universal development court helps to
usher them in i don't really know if
that's exactly what would happen but
it would be cool to kind of see them
referenced so following that lengthy
number four
we're into number three we are never
going to see this guy in the mcu
but i would love it if we did the
molecule man owen reese
i love the molecule man so the molecule
man originally had this amazing origin
story
and then it was made better by jonathan
hickman during his avengers new avengers
run but the molecule man owen reese was
basically the result of what happens
when a person absorbs the power of a
cosmic cube
here's a funny thing about this if
you're only familiar with the movies the
cosmic cube is the tesseract which is
secretly housing an infinity stone in
marvel comics
it's not that way a cosmic cube is
actually what happens when you absorb
energy from a realm called the beyond
verse which is
home to the beyonders and then you put
it inside a containment unit or a stasis
unit
which usually comes in the form of a
cube not always in the original infinity
war storyline we actually found out
that cosmic cubes look different in
other universes sometimes they're a
diamond
sometimes they're a circle whatever the
case happens to be so when the molecule
man originally got his powers what he
did was inadvertently create the process
by which
you create a cosmic cube but because
there was no stasis unit for that energy
from the beyonders to go into
instead half of it went into him and the
other half went out into the universe
and then eventually became the original
beyonder
now fast forward to jonathan hickman's
avengers and new avengers what you end
up finding out is that the molecule man
was actually created by design
that the beyonders were these beings who
existed beyond the multiverse in
what's quite literally called the beyond
verse and the idea is that the beyonders
would detonate all the molecule men at
the same time
because with that much power when he
died his universe would go with it this
guy
can do anything and because he can do
anything you're never going to see him
in the mcu
because he would turn into one of these
characters where you would find yourself
asking the question
if such and such rises to power or like
dormammu shows up or
some enemy appears why doesn't the
molecule man just fix it he's got the
power to do everything right so
you're not gonna see him in the marvel
cinematic universe so coming in at
number two
and i don't know if we're ever gonna see
this guy world breaker hulk
here's the thing i remember i was
sitting in the discord server if you
guys didn't know i have a discord make
sure you guys check the link down in the
description and it will send you there
but we had this discussion in the
discord server about potential scenarios
in the events of infinity war and
avengers in-game
and how it might have turned out
differently and my thought was i would
love to have seen world breaker hulk
even if we only saw him for a moment so
imagine like during the events of
avengers end game you have that great
huge fight towards the end
right and like the incredible hulk has
already snapped everybody back
but come to find out betty ross had died
but she had not died during the snap she
died during the assault on new york by
like the ebony maw or something like
that
and the incredible hulk realizes he
can't bring her back it's kind of a
complicated plot thread to throw in
there but
it would still be cool and so when the
incredible hulk realizes there's no way
to bring betty back maybe he hits up
iron man or somebody like that and says
hey see if you can scan for betty ross
to make sure she's okay and he's like no
man she's still dead
there's no way to bring her back the
incredible hulk snaps so you've got this
great big huge fight happening on like
the battlefield right you got like
the avengers and you have the full force
of battles and all that kind of stuff
and then you just hear this
sound deafening roar like everybody
stops and it's like what in the hell is
that
and then like the ground just starts
shaking right it's like an earthquake
under their feet
and like the incredible hulk is just
running towards thanos
full board and you're like oh my god and
then like somebody makes an offhand
remark like oh my god like he's gonna
break the world and that's when it's
like
world breaker hulk and like he just bam
tanks thanos in one punch because i can
promise you right now world waker hulk
could do it man the biggest problem you
have there is how do you
fix that how do you get the incredible
hulk
back down to his current form because i
promise you black widow running up on
him like hey big uh
the sun's getting real though that's not
gonna work
he's gonna be like i don't care you know
it's just let it set you know it's set
for me forever you know
i don't know but like that wouldn't work
right so it would be cool to see
like world breaker hulk in the mcu but
it's one of those things where they kind
of have to build up to it and at number
one
on our list and anybody who watches
comments explain knows
this guy was coming adam brashear the
blue marvel
i love this guy adam bashir has one of
the best comic book stories in the
history of marvel so check this out adam
beshear is basically a superhero before
pretty much all the other superheroes
right so like he was saving the world
before peter parker became spider-man
before the x-men reform before the
fantastic four went to space
got their powers and became the
fantastic four he was the hero before
all of them even before robert reynolds
took the modified version of the super
soldier serum that basically was a
thousand times more powerful than the
one that gave steve rogers his powers
and then became more or less like a
god-like character even before him
right like it was adam brashear but he
was a superhero during the early 1960s
but he alongside a friend of his name
connor sims were actually working on a
way to essentially
use anti-matter energy right so energy
from an alternate reality
as an energy source on earth but
ultimately the experiment goes awry
adam brosher gets blasted with all this
energy so he can effectively just
channel anti-matter energy for limitless
possibilities and he's considered a
stable anti-matter reactor
conor sims is not right he's crazy and
he loses his mind the power kind of
screws him up
and then it's also his just extreme
misanthropic view
and cynical view of humanity and so
eventually the two of them get into a
great big huge knockdown drag out fight
right now adam berscher's got his whole
costume on
the mask the cape the outfit the whole
nine yards and he ultimately defeats
conor sims
while everybody's cheering him on the
problem is he comes out of the rubble
his mask is torn
and the country learns he's a black guy
following that the country
freaks right the whole of black america
is like you have to side with us in the
civil rights movement you're one of us
you have power that could help us
at the same time the government and
white people are terrified because what
happens
if he decides to topple the federal
government nukes aren't going to stop
him the guy saved the planet from a
meteor the size of arkansas
right so that's obviously not going to
help so eventually he's called into the
office of president kennedy and kennedy
basically relays all the fears and stuff
that i just told you guys and adam
beshear's response is that's ridiculous
right i'm not going to side with black
america anymore that i'm going to side
with white america
i'm a champion of the world i protect
the world from threats it's not like
when a meteor is coming to earth
the meteor is like okay i'm gonna get to
get into the atmosphere i'm gonna split
into a zillion pieces
and only kill black or white people it's
like if a meteor crashes into the world
it's going to evaporate all life on the
planet so
uh i saved the world and then ultimately
kennedy's like that may very well be
true
but because of the political climate we
can't necessarily believe that so he
asked blue marvel to step
down and blue marvel does and then he
gives him the presidential medal of
freedom and then blue marvel gets pissed
and throws it in the moon and almost
cracks the moon in half and that's issue
number one the rest of the four issues
are basically this hunt by iron man
to try to find adam berscher and you
learn about all this stuff project wide
awake the whole nine yards but i would
love to see him in the marvel cinematic
universe dude his movie would be
amazing i would prefer a tv show and
honestly i would choose john david
washington as the guy to play him a lot
of people are saying like you should
know denzel washington should be the one
to play that guy
here's the problem it's much easier to
make john david washington look
older and have him play the character
for the next 15 years
than to try to make denzel washington
look younger and be limited to the next
five years on how long he can play that
character
i feel like people don't think about
that they just think about the idea that
they love denzel washington and he
should play the role
which admittedly is kind of cool but his
son's a much better pick so
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments section i'd love to hear
your all's top five list and i will
catch you all later
peace